So, to help a patient see progress,
you have to ask questions about things
just outside of pain score,
and you have to make them both
specific enough and general enough
that the patient
can see progress throughout.
Rachel Trobman, thank you so much
for joining me on 20 Minute Leaders.
Welcome.
Hi. Thank you so much
for having me, Michael.
Of course. Where in the world
are you right now?
I am in New Jersey.
South Orange, New Jersey,
which is not too far
from the city of New York.
That's an interesting name,
South Orange.
I like that.
Yeah. It's like it feels like a.
Go ahead.
Exactly.
But, that's exactly what it feels like.
But what I really
want to start talking about
is your fun fact.
You're in Peru, how do you get
to sew somebody's arm back
without even being a doctor?
Even if you were a doctor,
it sounds crazy.
What happened over there?
So, when I was in college,
I spent the summer living
in Urubamba Peru,
which is like a small town
in the Sacred Valley.
I was working for an NGO
and they put me,
because I was interested
in medicine and science
and a working at a hospital.
I didn't speak any Spanish at the time.
I spoke fluent French.
And the doctor that I was working with
didn't speak any English.
So, I would ask him questions in French
and he would respond in Spanish.
And that's how we got by.
And mostly what I was doing
was like doing patient intake,
taking notes,
kind of like setting
and doing triage for the doctor.
But one day he was,
I forget what he was doing.
He was like catering to another patient.
And this patient came in
having accidentally chopped his arm off
on his birthday.
And they needed somebody to, like,
start doing the sutures right away.
And the doctor was like,
"You could get started."
And I was like, "What do you mean
I could get started?"
And he was like,
"Just there's all the tools
that you need are in the room."
And so, I was like, "Okay."
I'm terrified just listening to this.
I was like, okay,
I guess we're doing this.
And they needed hands.
And then, of course, he joined me
and we finished up the job.
But there's nothing quite like
a threat of just, you know,
losing Hanukkah toys.
And so, I,
yeah, so that's what happened.
That's how I did it.
And thankfully,
I didn't have to do it again.
The most important question.
Yes?
Is the man okay?
Is the person okay?
He is totally fine.
Yeah.
I went on to do other x-rays.
I did not go on to become a doctor.
I realized that like emergency room
trauma was like not my thing.
But it was, yeah,
it was one of those things
where like I guess
you learn on the ground,
but it's not, anywhere else,
that would not be acceptable.
But there, the guy lived totally fine.
And that's the story.
Amazing. I love that.
I definitely feel
my heart pumping and terrified
as you're telling that story.
And just imagining myself
in that situation.
And I don't know
if I could have done what you did.
So, that's very impressive.
But, Rachel,
even more impressive
is the, your really unique
and amazing journey that you've had.
Both in the medical side,
but also in journalism
and production and media,
which is where I believe
you spent quite a long time in
partially, being a contributing author
to in The New York Times,
of all places, which is incredible.
And now, most recently transitioned
into the role of the CEO
of Upside Health with Ouchie
as one of the products.
So, Rachel, I have to understand
a little bit about your journey
before we dive into
the digital health markets.
Talk to me about how do you go
across these different industries?
Yeah. Well, I mean, for me,
it really started from,
I was always interested
in telling people stories
and in journalism and media,
particularly in health journalism.
And I got my first job
at New York One where I was
on the digital side of things.
And in the early days
of digital journalism,
it was really just like taking stories
that were made for production,
for TV, and then editing them
into something that would work
somewhat digitally.
And everyone assumed
that digital journalists were coders
at that time.
Anyone that was on the web
was considered a coder.
But I was just like,
it was the first job I was able to get.
So, I was a good writer
and was able to do it.
But being in that position
offered me a lot of opportunities
to like, try my hand at shooting,
try my hand at reporting
and try my hand at editing.
And it also gave me a chance to work
with content management systems.
And so, I got pretty good
at what I was doing
and was approached to join
a digital media company as a first hire.
And that was my first foray
into the startup world.
And while there,
and I have always been somebody who,
as was attested by
the hand sewing experience,
if there was an opportunity
to learn something
in real time, I'll take it.
I say yes before I say no.
And so, here was an opportunity for me
to immerse myself in something
that I was very confident
that I could execute
but I had never done before.
And then I quickly moved
into business development and strategy,
built the team from
zero to like a billion lifetime views
in just two years.
And this is kind of on the side,
but my husband's a software engineer,
he's a technologist.
And in the early days
of iPhone development and apps,
we decided to try our hands at that.
I would do the content
and he'd do the development.
And so, we got really good at it as well.
And it was a skill at that time
that not many people were doing.
So, people started hiring us
to build apps for them.
And so, I left my
content development role
and kind of moved it
into this new space
and started building for
you know, Fortune 500 companies,
startups,
really leading product strategy,
knowing that like being
a good storyteller
could transform based off the platform.
And so, if you know
how to tell a good story
and make something compelling
that people want to use
or want to read
or want to experience,
you can transfer that skill.
And so, when we got confident enough
that we could build something
from ideation to execution seamlessly,
I decided we were ready
to turn our attention
to something more personal.
Which kind of brings us to Upside Health.
When I was 17, I was diagnosed
with the connective tissue disease.
That was incredibly painful.
But I was a unique,
albeit unfortunate advantage
and that my mom has lupus
and my brother has cystic fibrosis.
So, I grew up in environments
where managing complex
chronic health conditions was the norm.
Having a built in supportive environment
was always there.
And yet, even with all of these things,
I found that pain was a tripping point.
Right?
There is no seamless easy way
to manage pain
because pain, unlike some
of the other metrics
that are being managed,
are really subjective.
And when a primary symptom
of what you're living with
is something that is really subjective,
it becomes hard to communicate around.
It feels hard to get validated.
And it is hard to treat
from just not like the patient perspective,
but also from the clinician perspective.
Something that people don't know,
maybe not think about
with like a lot of patients
who have chronic diseases,
is they spend a lot of time
with their doctors.
And if you're someone like me
who has a journalistic background,
who likes to ask questions
and hear answers,
you get to know
their pain points really well.
Right.
And understand that, like,
this wasn't just something
I was experiencing
as a patient saying, like,
this is hard to manage
and I'm frustrated
and I'm isolated,
but also something that
the clinicians would say like
this isn't easy.
It's not easy for me either.
And so, I found that
there was like an opportunity right there
to help facilitate change.
So, how does that actually
so, first of all, give you a little bit
of a broader perspective
into what's available today.
How many people are going through
somewhat of a similar experience
or need help managing that experience,
which led to your understanding
that there is actually,
not just an opportunity
to help some people,
but help a significant number of people
where it can actually be
a viable business
that becomes Upside Health?
Great question.
So, I mean, it's very clear,
I'm not running a nonprofit here
as much as I would love
to be able to help people
just from that.
But like, you have to,
I was interested in building a business
because I saw a substantial problem,
as I said, but also
a really large market opportunity.
I mean, there are 50 million Americans.
Right.
Some people will say
100 million Americans,
but I'm going conservative
and saying 50 million Americans
who live with chronic pain.
20 million of them.
Yes.
So, that's more than
I think, heart disease
and diabetes combined.
If you add in like 100 million,
that's diabetes, heart disease
and cancer combined.
Looking at the number is enormous.
And 20 million of them
live with debilitating chronic pain.
So, that's the kind of chronic pain
that limits your ability to work,
to socialize,
to conduct functional life tasks.
And so, that population,
though is only being served
by about 4000 pain specialists.
Meaning that there's
less than one pain specialist
for every 10 thousand Americans
who live with chronic pain.
Wow.
So, 95% of chronic pain patients
don't get access to specialized care.
And then even those who do,
those are pain specialists
who we're seeing 40 patients a day
and are being incentivized
for the injections and the procedures
and not necessarily for lengthy visits
that discuss medication history.
Like it's just, it's the way
that the system is set up.
Plus, they're doing their best
to see as many patients
as they can
because there's so few people
to offer this care.
The other challenge with chronic pain
is like, as I mentioned, you know,
It is subjective in many ways,
but it's also best served
by multi-modal solutions.
What do you mean by that?
So, when pain is last longer
than like six months,
which is what would be defined
as chronic pain, solutions that cater
to the bio, social, emotional,
like bio-psycho social environment
are the most effective.
Because pain, at that point,
is not just coming
from a physical location,
it's coming from pain signals
that are being sent from the brain.
There is normally a depression
or anxiety component.
There's an isolation component.
There's a movement component.
And so, unless you are providing
a multidisciplinary solution,
you're going to have limited outcomes.
But I mean, what I just explained to you
is not scalable
by most health care providers
or most health systems,
like in a traditional
brick and mortar fashion.
You really need,
this is like an opportunity
that's ripe for digital intervention
because you just can't offer that service
or those services en masse
to people who are already
having difficulty moving, right?
Like, getting a patient
to go to one doctor's visit
is hard enough when they're
in so much pain.
Getting them to go
to three different visits,
remember them,
might get value from them,
have insurance cover them
is just it's really hard.
Right. And I guess,
that's where Upside Health comes in.
So, how are you actually helping,
you know, this incredible market,
that I'm shocked by the magnitude of it
that we're talking about
50 million Americans,
conservative speaking,
that have some sort of chronic pain?
How do you help them?
Well, and the other thing
to note about this
really large market size
is that we're also talking
about incredible amount of spending
within a health system.
So like, an average chronic pain patient
goes to the doctor 19 times a year.
It costs the health system $34,000.
So, there is more than $600 billion
spent every year in chronic pain cost.
So, I mean, this is not just
like a big market,
but it's a really expensive one
for health systems payers
really across the board.
So, how do we help?
How do we solve this?
It's really about providing
a multifaceted solution
that providers can easily distribute
to their patients that allows
for not just behavior change
on the point of the patient,
but that behavior change
creates a reduction in clinical burden.
It also creates a decreased cost
for a system
and then incentivizes providers
through it being reimbursable.
The software is mobile software
that uses the best
of patient reported data.
So, everything on mood,
sleep, functional ability
and then passively collected
physiologic data
to help the patient better understand
what's happening with their pain.
We help them set goals
towards treatment like what would be,
if their pain were 50%
less, for instance,
what they would do differently.
And then based off of this information
that they provide and that we gather,
we connect them
to a curated cohort of other patients,
to ensure that nobody hurts alone.
We also direct them
to integrative wellness content.
So, something that responds
to their particular needs
at a particular time.
So, let's say the patient is
reporting that they are
having difficulty sleeping
or sleeping under six hours a night,
that sleep is restless.
We know from their physiologic data
that we've gathered
that they have been rather sedentary.
And their goal is
to be able to go grocery shopping
so they can have
some nutritious meals in their house.
The content that we provide
maybe in at meditation's,
exercises, stretches,
information about like sleep hygiene,
interactive content around
preparing a grocery shopping list,
for instance,
and then support from other patients
and our health coaches
to help them reach those goals.
And then the clinicians,
on the other hand,
get to view this high level data.
We synthesize the data,
we review it with our clinical team,
and then we offer them everything
that's required to build,
so, that way they don't have
to take that on internally.
Interesting.
So, walk me through the process.
If I have, let's say
I have chronic back pain, right,
and I'm looking for that support.
What is my interaction
with this app on a daily basis?
As well as, how does
this connect to the triangle
where the patient,
the physician and the app?
How does that happen?
Yeah. So, you I mean,
you could find the app for free
on the app stores.
But really our primary
distribution model now
is through your provider.
So, you were going
to either your a pain specialist,
your primary care provider,
your neurologist, your orthopedist,
and they're saying
we're now using this.
We think that is
medically beneficial and necessary
for you to be part
of this remote patient monitoring
and behavioral health platform, Ouchie.
Here's how you download it.
Somebody from their team
will also reach out
to help on board you.
You'll create an account
where you enter some basic information
and then we'll start pulling
the data right away.
And then based off
of the data that we're pulling,
we'll send your prompts and reminders
about changes in your activity
to say, like, okay,
we've seen these changes,
how do you now respond
to these various
patient reported information.
And here is some content
and community that we think
that will support you.
Now, you're like for four days of trying
this non opioid based treatment,
away from like earning a prize.
And then me,
the doctor who has introduced this to you,
can look in real time and see this.
Or, I could see the monthly reports
at the end of each calendar month
that I received from the Ouchie team
that will give me the insights
in how you've been engaging,
what activities you've tried,
what successes you've had,
how your medication use has changed,
what are the correlations
between this and that.
And then the doctor has
the ability to act on that,
but also to be able
to bill insurance for that.
Right. And it sounds like there's
a lot of things that
this is helpful with.
First, that it allows
the distribution of access, right?
So, you can have some pain specialists
that are now looking at
and supporting multiple
greater factor of patients
because they're not necessarily looking
and spending an hour
on which they are looking
at higher level data.
You can obviously synthesize the data
and then come up with some
interesting conclusions.
I'm curious about
the user experience side of things.
Because one of the things
that you're mentioning
with habit formation and goal setting,
which is something
that many apps try to do, right?
The notorious to-do list
app that you can write
a million to dos,
and never follow through with them.
So, talk to me a little bit
about goal setting
and habit formation
in the context of chronic pain,
and how you're
tackling that through user experience.
So, one of the problems
with the way that we've gathered
and measured pain in the past
is it's like solely dependent
on the pain score.
And so, it's really hard to see progress
if like every time you're asked
what your pain level is,
it's a level eight.
And there's so many reasons
why a patient will give level eight.
Maybe they really
are in excruciating pain.
Maybe the doctor
won't take them seriously
if they say six.
Maybe they,
I mean, there's just a lot.
So, pain score,
a lot of times doesn't vary.
And so, to help a patient see progress,
you have to ask questions
about things just outside of pain score.
And you have to
make them both specific enough
and general enough that the patient
can see progress throughout.
So, we tie progress
to small functional tasks,
but based off of
what the patient is changing
in their pain score
or their mood in their sleep,
we'll rearrange them
in a different order.
So, that way the patient can see progress.
And the progress will change
based off of various other scores.
And also, there's some things
that we ask in terms of smart goals.
You know, if you're paying
there's also the way
that you ask a question, right?
If you're paying were 50% less,
what would you do differently.
We're not asking patients
to complete tasks
for the sake of completing tasks.
We're giving them
tasks that are part of their regular life
and asking them
how close they are to completing it.
And then we reward them for things
that they might not realize
that are our accomplishments.
But sticking with something,
for instance,
it's almost like the surprise of
you've been hanging in there.
That's a reward, cheering on other users.
And then through time,
those things become a habit.
Every time our users update,
they have an option
to either post privately
just for themselves
or their provider, or publicly,
to the Ouchie community.
And what we see
is a lot of users start posting privately
but are still engaging
in the cheer and support of others.
And then over time,
they transition into being part of
the community in a more complete way.
So, we aren't forcing the users
to do anything
that they're not doing,
but bit by bit like introducing
behavior change techniques.
I think the other thing that,
you know, is missed a lot of time
with just like forcing
a program onto somebody
is not meeting them
where they're already at.
So, with chronic pain patients,
a lot of these patients
have been dismissed.
A lot of these patients
have had to go to a lot
of different providers before
they find one that is specialized.
As I mentioned, there's not a lot
of specialized providers.
So, a lot of patients
are still being seen
by their primary care doctor
who doesn't have enough time.
And so, creating an immediate contact
with the patient of acknowledgment
and recognition and say,
okay, we see that
these are the problems
that you're having right now,
here are some solutions
right on this platform
that can help you with that
and then we'll introduce something
maybe that you haven't thought of.
But until you can address some
of their immediate need,
it's really hard to gain the patient's
trust that, like,
we're really on their team.
We're not just trying to like,
force something upon them
that the doctor once.
I don't know if that makes sense.
And then we have to build
that trust on a clinical side as well.
Then we have to build this trust
on the clinical side as well that like
we're not trying to create
more work for them,
that we know
how challenging our jobs. We are like,
we have to build
not like a marketplace,
but you do have
two different types of clients
that you're trying to support.
100%. And it makes perfect sense
that the complexity is there,
the importance of it is there
the you know,
the sensitivity is there.
Because I think,
one of the interesting complexities
that you're introducing here,
the layer of the user experience
of trying to identify the pain
and measure something
that is qualitative not quantitative,
but you're trying to do it
in a way that is aligning incentives.
Because at the end,
your incentive is to gauge the real pain
so that you can help them form
their habits and pass that information
to the physician.
Their incentive is to get better.
And there is sort of this misalignment
in the industry right now
where if you don't,
if sometimes you're not
you know, dramatic enough
or exuberant enough about it,
then perhaps people are not going
to take you seriously enough.
Especially I'm guessing,
in an industry where you're saying
that there's 95% people
that don't have the care
that they need to have.
So, it sounds like what you're doing
here is hugely, hugely important.
I do have to apologize
that I should have called
this show 30 minute leaders
are not 20 Minute Leaders.
But Rachel, this has been fascinating.
And I want to thank you for being
generous with your time.
My last question is,
the most important one,
which is the three words
that you would use to describe yourself.
Tenacious.
Passionate.
And compassionate almost to a fault.
I like that. I like that.
And I'm sure that you have
to have those things in order
to do what you're doing there.
And I wish we could talk more about it,
about the journey
and the transition from journalism
and production and media to this.
But this is all wonderful.
Rachel, thank you for helping
improve people's lives.
I love businesses that are taking
people that need help,
finding a good business solution
that is a win-win situation.
I truly believe that in order to make
a real impact, there has
to be aligned incentives.
People don't work for free.
In order to have
the best people with you,
it needs to be a viable business.
And that's why I am
unapologetically saying
we're not a non-profit,
we're a for profit business,
but we're helping improve people's lives.
And that's a win win situation
that is beautiful.
So, thank you for doing that.
And stay safe and stay healthy.
Thank you.
Thank you so much for having me.
And you stay well as well.